might like loaded stomach be from Hashimoto or something else that should have probiotic help.
Well probiotic isn't going to help Hashimoto so if you have Hashimoto's you also have to
make sure absolutely positively that you are gluten free so gluten is a molecular mimic cross
reactant to vital problems so you cannot eat gluten so again go to the autoine course I have an
entire module on Hashimoto's so make sure you look up that you haven't but if you're eating gluten
dairy can be across reactant to gluten you're eating gluten a dairy with Hashimoto
if you do anything's game I mean that could be it also consider doing a cyrox 10 if you have
bloating if you're if you're not take if you're already taking HCl with digestive enzymes
consider uping that for a period of time if to eat a cyrox 10 is out of the financial consideration
so all those things to think about with Hashimoto's Hashimoto's in itself is not going to cause
bloating but comorbidities that go along with Hashimoto's which are food sensitivities
gluten definitely cross reactant inflammation creating antibodies to gluten and dairy
are all causes of bloating and grade fog grade inflammation so be careful of all of those things
the getting we tested for cross reactant foods like it's something you want to look at too so for
person it's like I have Hashimoto's and I would gluten free and dairy free for years and I'm still
having these issues while you could have other issues with other foods so anything so your auto immune
do you have antibodies to your self tissue anything that's going to cause inflammation it's going to
cause your immune system to get worse that's the problem when you have cancer so we have cancer you
have to be stimulating your immune system to kill the cancer but every time you're stimulating
your immune system you're affecting your autoimmunity so it's a catch 22 but it's like okay well I
get a deal with these symptoms of Hashimoto's and kill my cancer or am I going to you know
let succumb to cancer and have less Hashimoto symptoms so let's you have to play with that balance